there is a vital link between the Hamas
offensive and the atrocities it
committed and the history of the
conflict which involved Arabs attacking
Jews initially a massacring Jews in
various places such as kbron in 1929 and
Israelis massacring Arabs in the 1948
war and continuous back and forth
between Arab gorilla or terrorist
attacks Palestinian and Israeli
retaliation and counter Insurgency in
the schools in the West Bank and
especially under Hamas and the Gaza
Strip hatred has been taught the kids
from the moment they were born
essentially and they grow up hating Jews
and hating the state of Israel for what
it has done and has done a things to the
Palestinians without of course them
being taught the things the Arabs have
done to the Jews and this is a product
in some way of that